I'm Diane Campione I'm interviewing today for Visible Lives at the JCC.
Center ?along? special needs fair. Today I'm speaking with... Kathy Nowak
Hey Kathy, who's story're you telling us about today? My son, Michael.
And can you tell me what made you suspect that Michael was different?
I really didn't because he was very engaged and happy as a young, uh,
infant and it was only when, at 11 months
approaching 12
12 months that he wasn't meeting his ?small motor? skills
?? my pediatrician led me into early intervention and then from there
Tell me about the day that Michael was diagnosed. Um, it's different, you know
alot of times when people talk about what happens when he's diagnosed
people assume your child has autism. I mean ?inaudible?
?inaudible? um, so it took- it was a long journey.
Very long. Not 'til 11 months old that he
diagnosed with an intellectual disability. [See ya, take care] And, um, so the
classification they gave him was autism? Intellectual disability.
intellectual disability. How would you describe your emotions after
you first heard that dis- that diagnosis. For me it was okay.
because my ?fears? was
classified as. Right. So it was a gradual, and gradually
and the ?? diagnosis was changing
?inaudible?
What, what word best describes the difficult stages of Michael's disability?
Say that again.
What word would you say best describes the difficult stages of his disability?
would it be, um
Anger or, um [yeah]
[background talking].
Well how 'bout let me ask you this. What would you say was the biggest obstacle for him to
overcome? I would say the biggest
one that continues is, uh, his motor. When he
was approaching adolescence his motor
abilities changed and where he could sit at three years old with a
?11 years old?? and at this point at 25
he needs assistance eating and he's very ?aware? I mean
he, he understands, he's
for lack of a better word, high functioning, he has language, he has sense of humor
He can tell me "I need help" when his tremors are so bad
So, I would, I would think ?the motor?.  And
And do you ever feel as though you gave up your life to give Michael a life?
No. ?Never? [chuckle]
Do you or did you ever ask why?  No
I always said well, why not? Why, why not me?  Like if it's not me
then it'd be someone else. So
No. Is there something you would like the public to know about
individuals with, um, intellectual disabilities?
[Oh]
[background talking] Just to always remember that they are people that have feelings and they understand a lot more than people think
be careful what you say because sometimes ?it comes? right back.
Absolutely. Finish this sentence for me. I draw my strength from
from
[Background noise] ?inaudible? Well.
This interview was beautiful and I thank you for sharing your story with me your answers were
so honest and open and I really appreciate your being a part of Visible
lives. They look you back.